so because i have a few extra minutes
with you today i might have a few
sideball quite a few curveballs if you
will if if someone has never seen
anything that you've done what's the
first thing you want them to watch and
why
oh my lord that's a curveball
oh well i guess uh
i guess
you know what a movie that i directed
called a walk on the moon
one that's very to my heart i don't even
act in it but it's a i think it's a
beautiful film and was very much from my
heart so that one
um yeah
yeah there's the answer
sure uh you have not directed a feature
since i want to say conviction in 2010.
um
but you've been directing a lot since
then um have you been developing any
other features or have you really been
enjoying the television thing
uh no i've devised two features that i
want to make now um we're just putting
them together so uh that but yeah during
scandal i couldn't
direct a feature so it was sort of why i
hadn't ever done a television series
before because i knew it would prevent
me from you know directing anything long
form
but uh so that was seven years and since
then it you know takes a while to get
things going so um i do enjoy directing
television as well but um uh features
are are
i find really exciting so i have a
couple that hopefully will uh be
in the mix in the next year or two
i'm curious how long did it take how
many years after ghost came out that you
could walk down the street and people
not give you bad looks
really not until scandal honestly
i mean the bad looks were they they they
softened up a bit over the years
but until this came on the scene people
completely identified me with that you
know most of all with that character of
carl bruner and ghost
sure when you showed the film to your
kids how long before they talked to you
again
oh they they weren't they they
didn't feel that way you know actually
my younger daughter had never seen it
and about 10 years ago or something uh i
would say that done and watched it
together and uh it was nice she must
have been about
10 or 15 or something so
uh yeah but then they don't hold that
stuff against me no i'm i'm just i'm
just teasing um
jumping into why i get to actually talk
to you i want to start i've seen the
whole series i want to start with
congratulations um and uh
i don't know how i can word this but i
didn't really know the whole story i'd
heard about it and i was wondering how
you were gonna play into capturing the
person because i'm watching the first
few episodes i'm like how is he gonna do
this and then all of a sudden i started
realizing and i'm like oh wow so i'm
just going to say you know
well done oh thank you thank you you
know what was it
what was it about the material that said
i want to do this or was it sort of
getting to play sort of two sides
yeah i think well that was probably the
main thing you know like i was when i
read the script i was fascinated by it
because um i think when i
read it they hadn't written all the
scripts they just i read the first
episode
where bruce is not actually in that much
but i saw there's a great turn at the
end of the first episode where you
realize whoa this guy's a whole other
person than we see seems to be um
so that grabbed me and then they sent me
some scenes that they were working on of
bruce in the later episodes and his
character goes places you just can't
believe so
that was super attractive uh but also
you know i remember
vividly you know when the anthrax
attacks happened and yet i didn't know
this story at all
so uh
that uh uh really really attracted me so
it's an incredible
odyssey
yeah one of the other things i think the
series does very well is that um there's
like not one wasted scene like there is
no
wasted time that all six episodes are so
fast um can you can you sort of talk
about that aspect
well i just think that kelly and brian
who wrote it you know compressed this
story um to be just jam-packed you know
the way that they
remained uh true to the spirit of the
truth you know
of what exactly happened of the facts
get the science all exactly right
um but maintain this dramatic momentum
over an investigation that lasted seven
years that really is impressive because
um it keeps you kind of on the edge of
your seat the whole time i found
oh 100 there are some scenes where you
are really um you know you got to
deliver some performances in this um
when you have like a scene that you
think is going to be a little bit
challenging say it's going to be on a
monday how do you typically like to get
ready
uh for that sort of day are you like a
week out already thinking about it like
can you maybe take me through your
process yeah months out really i mean i
i
you know one of the nice things about
doing i mean if it's a feature film i
need a lot of time but this because
we shot over a period of four months
you know i i had some time i knew what
was coming up way down the road so i
spent a lot of time
working on scenes well in advance of
when i was going to do them
uh because in this particular case you
know so much of bruce's behavior is
impacted by a hidden inner life
so you you know he's just a really
complex tormented person uh and he
starts to lose it as the series goes on
um
yeah so i just make sure that a good
week or two i'm already thinking about
it so it can kind of seep into myself
that's really what i hope for is that
it's kind of by the time we get to
filming it
it's kind of logged in my subconscious
as opposed to you know right up here and
then
um i just
try and make sure i
get whatever rest i can or so let me
it's going to be my concentration and
meditate and do all kinds of things to
just
be present when i'm about to do
difficult stuff
yeah i've spoken to a lot of actors and
they talk about how the night before
they barely sleep and others are like i
just sleep like a baby whatever's gonna
happen is gonna happen
no it depends it depends on me you know
it depends on it depends for me with
this one i
i had you know significant anxiety
leading up to some of these scenes
because i knew a lot was demanded of me
and i wanted to get it right you know
so i didn't lose too much sleep but i
had a little bit of tossing and turning
well you have also i think a different
perspective because you've directed so
many different things you know what
maybe the director's looking for i mean
how is that as
with all your directing how has it
impacted you as an actor in terms of you
know maybe maybe change i don't know
like you know what i mean like how is
that dynamic worked together yeah it
helps me a lot it it it really helps me
a lot because i do have a sense of like
um how i can be helpful to a director
and it helps me and know what to ask the
director like what's important for them
or how are they thinking about something
and
you know oftentimes i'll have a sense of
how they might cut something um you know
how they might something you might work
in the editing room or when there's a
camera you know i can understand what
the camera's doing in a way i couldn't
when i was when i was only acting but um
it i i find that it relaxes me because i
do have a sense of an understanding
about how it all comes together which i
did not have before i started directing
yeah how much are you looking at the
lens and be like oh he should be using a
75.
never
never i never do that i've never once
done that something i'm like oh i would
never have thought to do that i wonder
why that's i don't know how that's going
to work you know i i
nobody you know directing is so hard i
would never presume to know better than
a director what they're
yeah i'm just i'm just messing around it
was people who's asked me that all the
time and it's really true
yeah um so uh i you have some really
good scenes with daniel uh can you maybe
talk a little bit about collaborating or
just doing some of those scenes together
yeah do we it was great because daniel
um and i uh you know our
um
stuff comes in very late so even though
we're the two main characters you follow
our stories separately and we don't
um
you know we are we don't meet until uh
the fifth episode so we talked a lot
about that scene that happens which is
this great nine minute i think scene
uh where we we sort of had this ted
octet uh so it was it was we were both
very excited when we finally got to it
and it was it's one of my favorite
scenes in the in the show uh and then we
have another one in the final episode
which was really beautiful i thought and
uh
it was great so we became friends and
we're you know but every time we just
pass each other
on set never in the same thing so it was
very exciting we finally got to
you know get get into it together
if i'm not mistaken you shot a a movie
with gerard butler called the plane
yes i just finished that a few weeks ago
right
um i was gonna say he i've learned that
he is like the biggest international
star like whatever he does gets
financing it's i've learned so much
about him what was it like working with
me
yeah again
no that's amazing it's true yeah it's i
i have some producer friends that have
explained this to me that if he wants to
do a movie it gets made um
what was it like working with him it's
my last question what was it like
working with him and what can you tease
about the movie
well um i didn't work with gerard so
this the movie is about gerard plays
this um uh uh an airline pilot and
the you know flying from asia to the us
and um he's flying for sort of a
third-rate airline because he'd had some
difficulties and the plane goes down
over a small island in the philippines
and flies through a storm and
he ends up um they lose the plane
and
the you know the no one can better where
he is and it's gerard is trying to
protect the passengers because they end
up on a an island that's controlled by
filipino rebels who want to hold them
for ransom and kill them and
jerry is the hero of that so i play
this security consultant sort of ex-cia
special forces security consultant hired
by the head of the airline to come in
and
find this plane before it's too late so
i'm all in this like situation room and
i get my my mercenary soldiers to go in
and parachute in to rescue the plane but
meanwhile you know we've all been
watching um you know jerry do his jerry
butler thing you know uh uh in an action
movie so i'm we didn't we we our scenes
together are um
uh
over a video conferencing thing so we
didn't he was in the jungle and i was in
on a stage you know so
but
anyway
yo no i mean i have a lot of jokes i can
make but i got to stop there and i'm
just going to say congrats on this i
really did think you did a great job and
thank you for talking to me again twice
in a week
i really appreciate it's good to see you
nice to see you